[Music]
this morning on the ditch the man
credited with introducing Americans to
high-end food wine and hospitality from
the islands of Greece born in Greece
Kostas Philly at ease first arrived in
the United States in 1966 he settled
here in New York City to study
criminology but then this rarely go
according to plan they never do today he
owns international dining and
hospitality Empire with seven locations
around the world his restaurants each
named Melo's are know not only for
serving the finest ingredients in
freshest seafood but also for their
impeccable service chef Kostas Philly at
ease good morning and welcome good
morning thank you so happy to be here
it's so it's so good to have you here
tell me what we have here oh my god
little sample of what we we offer to our
customers let's start with some
beautiful octopus this time in
particular the octopus comes from the
northern Greek island of Lemnos and it's
accompanied by father father it's a it's
a legume that is growing in Santorini
and because of the microclimate of
Santorini and the fact that almost never
rains there everything grows very slowly
but very densely and very very beautiful
so the father there's a door in here a
very particular flavor so moving from
the octopus and the father we have some
grilled peppers of different colors and
then the the Greek spreads which is a
very typical way of putting together a
table that people can say my favorite
foods I said to you when I sat down my
favorite cuisine might easily be
grateful but your background is so
fascinating because you came here from
Greece at 19 and you've called it just a
totally lost that you were a lost
experience how do you go from that to
all of this what were those life I came
to actually New York
in 1996 with a student visa to study at
NYU and I faced you know a very huge
cultural shock yeah which for me at that
time it was very difficult - yeah you
got homesick very much so very much so
so I moved to Maryland my brother was
living there so it was a more
comfortable situation to be and
eventually I went to Montreal in Canada
you were a local radio I was a founder
of a community-based nonprofit local
radio station in Montreal together with
members of different communities we
started this community radio station and
I spent almost six years the culinary
world so to speak an interesting way I
mean you you you and your buddies kind
of got together and you just needed to
eat we needed to eat and we needed to
eat the way that we knew at home how to
eat so you called your mom on the phone
I it was my only source of knowledge I
mean I had no idea when I opened the
restaurant in Montreal in 1979 I had no
training in the culinary arts all I knew
was that food at home was a wonderful
good I could not find at that time
around me so I decided to bring back the
in America and in Canada the Greek food
as I understood it and I experienced it
at home which you've been doing ever
since and the attention to detail is so
obvious in everything that we are
tasting here I'm gonna have you sign our
dish five pound lobster is incredible to
look at yeah you could have this meal
with anyone past or present who would it
be my grandchildren I have six of them
and
these are the biggest thing in my life
life now it's a blessing yeah yeah thank
you so much you have Seymour on chef
Costas Billy at ease you can go to our
website at CBS this morning calm